- [Instructor] In previous
videos, we've gone into
reasonable depth on the
narrative of how the Sikh
religion was started,
initially by Guru Nanak
and then it how it developed
under the next gurus
all the way until the
tenth guru and finally
as it was compiled in
the Guru Granth Sahib,
which is considered by Sikhs
to be the last and final guru.
Sikhism is oftentimes compared
to both Hinduism and Islam,
sometimes with reference to
the idea that it has elements
of both, while others would argue that no,
it is a completely independent
religion and any similarity
is just coincidental, so let's
tackle that central question.
What elements of continuity
does Sikhism represent?
And in this video, we're
gonna think about continuity
in terms of religious
continuity and in particular,
does it have elements from
Islam or Hinduism in it?
So we could first focus on
some of the cultural trappings
or some of the historical
trappings of Sikhism
and think about the connections
to both Hinduism and Islam.
The first obvious connections
is that Guru Nanak,
the first guru, and
many of the early gurus
grew up in Hindu families.
But there are also cultural
connections to Islam.
The Sikh religion emerges in
Punjab, which is where or near
the various Muslim rulers of
the time held their capitals,
whether we're talking
about the Delhi sultanate,
which was in power for over
250 years when Sikhism started
to emerge with Guru Nanak,
but also the Moghul empire,
which really developed in its
early stages at the same time
that Sikhism develops, so
that many of the followers
of Sikhism were both Hindu and Muslim.
A lot of the terminology
of Sikhism borrows words
and borrows ideas from
both Islam and Hinduism.
The word Allah is used
to refer to god in parts
of the Guru Granth Sahib
but so is the word Ram.
One of the first and closest
followers of Guru Nanak,
who was with him most of
his life was Bhai Mardana
and even today, many
pictures of Guru Nanak
would have Bhai Mardana in them.
Guru Nanak famously as
someone who was spiritually
precocious and spiritually curious,
traveled through India and
Persia and the Middle East
so he visited many temples
but there's also many historic
accounts of him going to
Mecca and performing hajj.
The Guru Granth Sahib, which
is considered the spiritual
book the 11th and final
guru for the Sikhs,
of the contributors to
them, you have Kabir,
who grew up in a Muslim
family, he lived either around
the time of Guru Nanak or in
the century before Guru Nanak
and would write about both Allah and Ram,
although he was often critical
of both Hinduism and Islam,
and you also have Shaikh Farid,
who was a Muslim Sufi writer
and spiritual figure and
he has also contributed
to the Guru Granth Sahib.
There's also important rituals
that come from Hinduism,
so for example, when Sikhs
pass away, like Hindus,
they are cremated, so
just looking at this list,
you immediately see that
there's definitely cultural
elements whether we're
talking about words,
whether we're talking about rituals,
whether we're talking about
even just the historical
narrative of how and where Sikhism started
that are closely tied to ideas of Hinduism
and closely tied to ideas of Islam.
But now let's look at the
scripture itself and see if
we can glean any more
similarities or differences.
This is the Mool Mantar
which means main mantra
or the basic teaching of
Sikhism and it comes from
Guru Nanak and this is
an English translation,
you'll see variations of
this but it essentially says
one universal creator
god, the name is truth,
creative being personified,
no fear, no hatred,
image of the undying,
beyond birth, self-existent,
by guru's grace.
Throughout the Guru Granth
Sahib and much of the writings
of especially Guru Nanak
focus on devotion to god,
the one universal god, and
so many of you might think,
well that seems to have
connections to Islam
but then you could say,
well even in Hinduism,
although there are many aspects
of god, the various deities,
but there's this notion of a
fundamental reality of Brahman
so maybe it has elements of
that or maybe this is just
independently developed but
there definitely are parts
of the Guru Granth Sahib
which seem to have elements
that are close to Islam.
This is a quote from Guru Nanak.
He is Allah, the unknowable,
the inaccessible,
all-powerful and merciful creator.
So one argument is he's using
the Arabic word for god,
he's using Allah.
Now another argument,
counterargument, would be well,
he's just using the language
that his followers knew
and many of his followers
were Muslim and so would have
used the word Allah for
god, but he is not saying
that it necessarily has to be the exact
concept of god as in Islam.
Now this is from Kabir.
Someone sets up a stone idol
and all the world worships it
as the lord, those who hold to this belief
will be drowned in the river of darkness,
and this is in the Guru Granth Sahib.
This notion of being against idol worship
comes out very clear in this
quotation and that is another
idea that is often associated with Islam.
But as I mentioned,
there's also many parallels with Hinduism.
In the first video on
Sikhism, I gave you this quote
from Guru Nanak, the world is
a drama, staged in a dream.
Which alludes to the Hindu notion of maya,
the physical reality is all an illusion,
we wanna pierce through that veil.
What should the yogi have to fear?
Trees, plants, and all
that is inside and outside
is he himself.
So this is an idea that
we get very clearly
from the Upanishads,
any notion of duality,
of me being different from
you or even one versus god,
it's all an illusion, all is one.
By the karma of past actions,
the robe of this physical body
is obtained, by his grace the
gate of liberation is found.
So clear references to the
Hindu notions of karma,
that action drives
consequences, that you enter one
physical body after another,
but that's not your true self,
the robe of this physical,
there's a true self
and eventually, through the
grace of the ultimate reality,
you might be able to have
liberation, have moksha,
so clear Hindu parallels as well.
One angle is that Guru Nanak
and Sikhism was attempting
a reformation of both, taking
elements that were compelling
in either and then purifying
them, making them more
internal focused, less focused on ritual,
less focused on the external,
and more focused on meditation
and the true self.
There's a lot of quotations
in reference to both religions
that make it clear that
it was something different
and is critical of at least
how both religions seemed
to be practiced in India at that time.
Guru Nanak famously
said there is no Hindu,
there is no Musalman.
Most people feel that he's
saying this distinction
that we make between human
beings based on these
belief systems, that
these are superficial,
that these are to some degree transient,
that we are all part of the universal,
part of the ultimate reality, part of god.
This is from Guru Arjan,
the Muslim god Allah
and the Hindu god Paarbrahm
are one and the same.
So here, trying to unify
these ideas, and listen,
this is in a context where many
of the followers are Muslim
and many are Hindu and putting it in words
that they understand.
My body and breath of
life belong to Allah,
to Ram, the god of both.
So once again it's this
bhakti, this devotional aspect,
surrendering to god and using
the terminology that would be
familiar to people in that
time and in that space.
So I encourage you, go
out there, research,
think about it for yourself,
Sikhism for sure has its own
unique identity and
pretty much every religion
is a product of the
context in which it emerged
and has elements from other religions,
whether or not that
was done intentionally,
whether or not it's chance,
there does seem to be parallels.
We can make a whole tree
of religions if we like,
if we put Sikhism right here,
the question mark of this
video is you have this narrative of Islam,
to what degree does it influence Sikhism?
And many would say that especially
the Sufi orders of Islam
have much to do with Sikhism.
Sufism is a school of Islam
that is more inward looking,
that is about devotional love to god
and that's what a lot of
Sikhism is focused on,
but as mentioned, one could
also think about Hinduism,
which is much older than
pretty much any other living
religion today and in other videos,
we talk about the bhakti movement,
which is about devotional
love to god, there's also a
school of thought in Hinduism
known as Vedanta, which is
more focused on the core
spiritual ideas of the Upanishads,
the notion of the ultimate
self, the ultimate reality,
escaping from the cycle
of births and deaths,
from samsara, achieving
liberation, moksha.
All of these ideas are in Sikhism
and to make the point clear
that all of our major religions
are connected to each other,
we can keep drawing this tree.
We talk about how Buddhism
springs out of Hinduism,
that Buddha was a Hindu and
it might have been in reaction
to some of the ritual and
the caste that Buddha saw
in Hinduism or at least in Hindu culture.
In fact, some of those same motivations
might have motivated Guru Nanak.
Islam, we talk about in other videos,
famously emerges from a
Judeo-Christian tradition.
The most important prophets
in Islam after Mohammed
are Jesus, Moses, and Abraham
and Christianity of course
comes out of a Jewish
tradition, Jesus was Jewish.
And one could say that there's
even some direct connections
between Judaism and Islam,
notions of not eating pork,
notions of halal and kosher,
ideas of circumcision.
And one could even argue
that Judaism and Islam
also have close ties to Zoroastrianism,
a very ancient monotheistic
religion and Cyrus the Great
of Persia was the one who
really spread Zoroastrianism
and he is considered a messiah
amongst the Jewish people
because he liberated them
from the Babylonian captivity,
helped them re-settle in Jerusalem,
and helped rebuild the
temple at Jerusalem.
Zoroastrianism also has ties to Islam.
Zoroastrians pray five times
a day just like Muslims,
they have the ritual
bathing before the prayer,
just like Muslims, at
the same time of day.
So once again, amongst
all of these religions,
they definitely came in
contact with each other
and you definitely have
ideas that are shared
amongst the religions, so with that,
I'll leave you with one
last quote from Guru Nanak.
And this one would arguable
be addressed to his Muslim
followers but it gives
you a sense of his trying
to bring people back to the internal,
trying to make people less
focused on external ritual,
external physical reality,
and more on internal goodness
and your actions being more important
than your words or your rituals.
"Make kindness your mosque,
sincerity your prayer carpet,
"what is just and lawful your Quran,
"modesty your circumcision,
civility your fasting,
"so shalt thou be a
Musalman," or a Muslim.
"Make right conduct your
Kaaba," making reference
to the pilgrimage site Muslims
go to and pray towards,
"truth your spiritual
guide, good works your creed
"and your prayer, the
will of god your rosary,
"and god will preserve
your honor," Guru Nanak.